usa la propiedad distributiva para
factorizar completamente esta expresión
no debe haber fracciones dentro de los
paréntesis en su respuesta final y bueno
tengo cinco cuartos más un cuarto de un
así que déjenme sacar mi libreta de
apuntes que lo tengo por aquí y date
cuenta que tengo el mismo problema cinco
cuartos más un cuarto de un así que
dejamos de escribirlo en un primer lugar
para que lo veamos aquí tengo cinco
cuartos cinco cuartos ya esto le voy a
sumar déjame cambiar de color les voy a
sumar un cuarto de un un cuarto de un de
lujo así que pensemos un poco qué es lo
que podemos factorizar de esta expresión
si te das cuenta en esta primera parte
tengo cinco cuartos más
un cuarto de uno por lo tanto parece ser
que podemos factorizar un cuarto y para
que esto sea mucho más claro déjame
escribirlo de la siguiente manera cinco
cuartos lo podemos escribir como un
cuarto un cuarto que a su vez está
multiplicando a cinco esto es lo mismo
que un cuarto que multiplica a cinco
mientras que por otra parte un cuarto un
bueno pues eso lo podemos escribir de la
siguiente manera como un cuarto un
cuarto que multiplica que multiplica a
uno esto multiplica a un un cuarto por
uno es lo mismo que uno por o entre
cuatro que es lo mismo que un cuarto que
multiplica a un y bueno si te das cuenta
de una manera muy clara aquí tenemos a
un cuarto como factor común así que
podemos factorizar a éste un cuarto y
nos va a quedar lo siguiente así que
vamos a factorizar éste un cuarto de
esta parte y este otro un cuarto de esta
otra parte y por lo tanto nos va a
quedar
cuarto que multiplica y bueno primero
multiplica a 5 ok y después multiplica a
y entonces esto más uno por si podemos
cerrar nuestro paréntesis y esta es
nuestra respuesta correcta así que es
hora de ponerla en nuestra página de
internet un cuarto que multiplica a 5
más 1 vamos a ver si me acuerdo un
cuarto que multiplica a 5 más 1 y es
hora de escribirlo justo aquí voy a
tener un cuarto
un cuarto a ok un cuarto que a su vez
multiplica aunque a su vez multiplica a
cinco más más y ok es momento de
comprobar nuestra respuesta y de lujo
estamos bien